all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown first one of a year
2016 the Club hosted a tournament called
chess 16 on January 2nd and there was an
under 1500 section the open was
obviously won by none other than a
grandmaster been feingold and but the
under 1500 had some very interesting
games and this is one of the biggest
comebacks we've seen in a while
so playing white is dr. Andrew Morris
against one of the students Christopher
Byron okay so they start out d4 d5 and
III and that's probably not recommended
blacking the net Bishop or it so knight
c6 gets his night out he pins the knight
so white decides I'm gonna pin your
knight so Bishop takes the knight
probably not recommended because you
really don't want to be capturing pin
pieces you'd rather try to attack them
but now he gets this Queen out to take
back and now he's decides he does not
want the double pawns of Bishop takes
Knight check so he blocks with the Queen
so if Bishop takes he can just take back
with tickle okay
so white decides to play a three does
anybody know why he might have had the
the reason why to play a three even
though it's a dubious reason so so white
thought if he just plays like a random
move the Queen could come down here and
when the bishop but what move could
white simply play so the Queen couldn't
take the bishop without major
consequences
93 excellent and then he'd be fine so
and another another move he could have
done if he didn't wanna get checked like
that is simply castle right all right
but he thought a three is gonna stop at
all okay or just play the move Knight c3
out right okay all right so a three a
six so I can't resist taking with check
and the Queen takes and so the Queen's
coming down on the pond so he brings out
his night it gets his night out and now
white gets castled so you'll see this in
a lot of amateur games they get Castle
on one side and their opponents like I'm
gonna castle on the other side and there
it is so it makes for a fun game but but
somebody might get checkmate early
you're good you can sit right are you
right up front yeah
alright so b3 much more ambitious is b4
trying to break open the open the lines
so Queen retreats it plays h3 here
c6 Knight a4 so he's threatening a big
check huh so maybe we want to do
something about that
I like it okay so he puts his queen to
protect the score so wait he's trying to
bust open that C file so he can
potentially pin the rook Queen and King
so now Christopher plays Knight attacks
the bishop okay and he's also
threatening you know a fork if he gets
it too so how would we go about this
situation any ideas
rookie won't learn work d1 right I'm out
I like that move actually
so so yeah that's fine
computer recommends Queen to e2 but yeah
the bottom line is you just want to
protect the bishop when he plays Bishop
to c3 it allows a tactic so basically
who is protecting the bishop somebody is
protecting the bishop the white knight
right but the white knight is easily
attacked right so so what should we play
here to win a piece and well we don't
actually go to a five because well it
attacks the knight it drops the Queen b5
excellent so so that's what you want to
play pawn takes which point where we
take back with the a or the C a plum
right because we don't want to break
open the C file for him and then he's
got to make the choice you know who do I
want to lose and so we would win a piece
instead he just takes it and and so he
survived that okay so bishop and now the
queen are in the same diagonal here but
is this very scary for for white it was
that check gonna kill you and in fact if
he plays that check and he and he
doesn't doesn't get out of it we can
play g3 and box in his Bishop and and
win the bishop so you much rather have
the Queen coming down first because it's
checkmate instead of just a simple check
okay so but he's gonna he's gonna deal
with it anyway
get checked so g3 clean up so so when he
plays his night back to a four what can
we take now that our Queen and Bishop
were working as a team again correct yep
good and so now he's going to try to box
in the bishop but as you'll see it's
gonna be too slow
so what move do we have to play now
because he just played c5 so yeah I mean
that looks good but unfortunately the
knight can take it OOP so we have to
play Bishop to b4 he gets our big
check-in and the King to be 8 so work to
a4 looks pretty good but we can protect
it with the pole all right so now he
offers the Queen trade and so White has
the opportunity to give black double
pawns and says he's like I don't want
you to have double pawns
I want the double points so that's
really not not very good so now he's got
his his double pawns going but I guess
he figured I can't get checked on the G
file but ok so h6 king up f6 hang up
we'll see in this in this in this game
white makes a lot of King moves but they
don't really get them get him too good
alright so now Christopher's got the G
file so very important rights rook isn't
doing too much over here he probably
wants to get that rook in the game
eventually but instead he's just gonna
move over his King a lot so he gets
checked and King up all right so now
White's got the G file so he's feeling
pretty good he's threatening check the
fork the pawn so so that was that was
good black really shouldn't have
conceded
the G file he should have checked with
the other rook WeDo we'll all right so
he's got a challenge of G file anyway so
he'll get the G file back so now he's
finally activated his rook so now he's
taking the G file back Bishop the e1
attacks the poem it's protected by the
rook so he's got to just do his own
thing a play rook check yeah so who so
we got two King moves here we can play
b8 or d8 anybody like anybody like to go
to d8 City eight what is what is not so
cool about going to d8 in this position
yes you can check made it okay we got a
whiz kid in the audience tonight I like
it I like it I like it and so yeah so we
don't want to walk into checkmate all
right so King to b8 all right so he gets
checked though and now a lot of pawns
are gonna fall here all right so we got
rid of all out of Queen side pawns here
and so Knight up Bishop attacks the rook
the only move to not lose the material
is rook over King backwards who likes
that move probably probably the player
playing black huh cuz he just
voluntarily removed the defender of his
pawn not very good all right so black
takes like another pawn so rook up
attacks it work over a four that was
that a good move for black no because
you only have one defender and he's got
to attack her so make sure you have just
as many defenders as the guy has
attackers but but luckily he doesn't see
it and plays check King now everybody's
favorite
opening guy Jonathan Trent's was taking
a look at this position and he came down
and told the guy's parents there's no
way he can lose even if he loses all his
pawns he still cannot lose this game so
so let's see if how good his pronounced
occasions are here all right
black jacket let's get the black rug
well yeah we got the black rook we still
might not win this game but so we got to
go for the King here yeah you still
might be able to get a passed pawn so
all right so he attacks he defends
attacks the bishop so bishop moves so
yeah yeah now he's threatening
discovered check but he's like you know
what I got such an insurmountable lead
and we don't even care I'm just gonna go
get my queen and I don't even care about
you and your discovered checks so he's
like fine if you don't care I'm not
gonna play discovered check then and so
now okay so now it's like okay nothing
this so big check King to b8 RC a king
bee hey this is which well that King
video King of b6 is the best but King's
c8 is played and and somebody is gonna
be really mad in about two seconds and
his name is Christopher Byron everybody
see what uh what white did to them mate
yeah always look for those checkmates
yeah the game 65 with a five-second
delay so they have plenty of time to
figure out not to get checkmated right
yeah a big big thing is don't walk into
checkmate you could just play here and
not quite but there could be in the
future you never know
alright so so that was a funny checkmate
here's another funny checkmate from
there from the game it's a regular on
beginner breakdown unfortunately a
Robert Beekman with white against Nate
alright so let's see how Robert manages
to do Roberts got the white pieces this
is the Sicilian I mean if you go to
tournaments yup I see this on the board
you know at least 25% of the games very
popular opening or it doesn't want to be
checked doesn't want any Knights to come
in that's fine so Bishop d3 not the most
active position for the bishop and it
also undefended so so he attacks the
knight Knight retreats bishop up bishop
so Knight attacks some stuff I mean much
much better is just you get castle and
safe and then you can go on and do all
the craziness so Bishop attacks the
knight takes the up Bishop Queen takes
Bishop you know pins the night so so he
wants to play h6 and once again like we
saw in the other game they just take and
just believe the pressure and and the
Queen gets active so that's the best way
to go so castle so wrap or Zaid Roberts
opponent is just going to play it safe
and Castle kingside notice
well castling queenside kind of
dangerous in a lot of positions this one
it would be even worse because the C
file is already open so so just you
there's nothing wrong with castle on the
same side as your opponent but Roberts
to see he's got to go for it with f4 but
what is wrong with the move F floor here
Robert is playing the white pieces he
just played f4
so notice you shall always look the
simplest solutions always the right one
rate sometimes so so you just want to
look okay what happens if I capture okay
he'll capture back either with the night
or the rook doesn't matter and then what
can uh where can my Queen go then it
couldn't when my plane was on e5 we
should be able to calculate you know two
three moves deep at snap it's not the
most complicated thing in the world yes
no well you do have a check but when we
rather we read have material and then if
he attacks us we can check them okay and
then we can save our beep on if we want
which probably do okay so instead he
just retreats the Queen and now the
white F point keeps going so g6 here
yeah yeah as a as a player in the
audience suggest that's really wasn't
the move there's no reason to to bring
open your kingside pawns when you don't
have to so now the Queen pins it and so
now he's like okay Queen up so captures
pawn takes pawn takes pawn takes and now
he's got to check King up and so it's a
black's pawn structure isn't isn't isn't
the best and whites should have a slight
advantage here rook attacks the pollen
so check so there's no real good way to
save this backwards pawn so he tries to
play some interference and put his
knight in between it but Roberts like go
away and so he does so your step takes
Bishop takes rook takes rook the c8 not
really threatening much so Knight up a
fire Knight up so now you decided hey
I'm gonna put my rook on an active file
here oh so so so I fortunately Robert he
wants to just attack his opponent's
[ __ ] up when he should have should have
been thinking about what threats he had
so another funny checkmate alright so
you gotta watch out
check making happen at any time if
you're not careful okay alright so we're
gonna give Robert some redemption even
though this checkmate isn't like the
funniest but we got to give him a win on
this series one time or the other so
this was round three he's like I'm not
kidding around after all this I'm just
gonna get you he's playing a guy that uh
Keith bass calls not very good so so
here no this guy isn't the best ease
plan alright so here we go so Roberts
got the white pieces and he's
looking for the crusher okay yeah
all right so Bishop the beef or not the
best place for the bishop so he attacks
that any sort of the bishop is on a good
day all right so he gets his Bishop on
the good diagonal threatening the
pivotal f7 square so Knight up pawn
attacks the bishop so we should probably
take it one way or the other
all right but instead I said he takes
the pawn so pawn takes the bishop Knight
takes and now we have a decent and well
we got a lot of decent moves buried so
Knight takes the pawn Knight to e4 so
he's just asking asking for it here
black black really needed to get castled
in this position for the only only way
to win but yeah wait has a lot of good
moves here I mean just take your pick
right Queen the d5 Knight takes up
sevens obviously the probably the best
Bishop takes check they're all good guys
not checkmate maybe it could lead to
checkmate though yeah unfortunately that
that that the knight would get us but
yeah we could play like maybe Queen here
that looks good it all looks good but
all right well Roberts got to take it
slow
all right coin 2 D 3 so Knight protects
f7 but he's like I don't care and so he
takes see your queen yeah yeah it's very
disappointing so now what do you want to
play here
no you have even better than take night
Roberts got no interest in taking that
night the black Bishop yeah check and
then we got another check check with the
Queen Queen down you know Queen here or
here there white space right cuz yeah we
don't want them running out off seven
all right so good for Robert II got on
the board gotta finish with a point you
know guys got a long way to go alright
so now we're gonna see how the champions
do it okay that the two guys that
actually won the you 1500 section okay
so we got Kirby Compton with white
against Bobby Casey alright alright so
Kirby is though he's the cold winner
along with Matthew Manley alright so
here comes Kirby alright efore it's the
Sicilian this is actually a really good
way to play against the Grand Prix
attack with this a six maneuver that way
his LightSquared Bishop doesn't have
much to do and you don't have to worry
about getting checkmated real quick so a
three see a lot of eight threes on the
under 1500 section that's alright
alright so that kind of maneuvering
blacks getting a lot of space so white
wants to kind of cramp them up with e5
so g3 he's gonna be in shadow is Bishop
here
so now he's gonna try to bust open on
the queenside here so now black has a
past a pawn here but it is isolated and
uh but long-term it could be a bad thing
it could be a good thing it just depends
on what you do with it
all right so black or white gets castle
here black should be a pie he thinking
the same thing
steadies gonna move this night around
but you never know you never know
alright so so he's gonna try to team up
and get this pawn but yeah there's a
knight there right right I'm to talk a
long term right all right so Queen Queen
up or is in the queen tree right and and
the computer is really love and white
here even though the materials equal it
just thinks White's just great so let's
see if if he can do something with this
advantage a positional advantage so
night there he found the Mook all right
so it's gonna be really tough for us to
protect this pawn saris nothing to try
yeah he doesn't even want to get when he
was gonna go there
so now Bishop protects the pawn but it's
just too late so King up and Nate
retreats attacks a new pawn right so so
he's got two players on it so it's gotta
be really tough for him to to get this
you know so so black made a lot of
nonsensical Knight moves early in the
game and uh he's paying for it now there
goes his past pawn g5 that goes his
night there goes his pawn alright
now almost mate so let's start working
on mate here Bishop takes g5 I like it
you do we want to go here or here left
you're correct you want to go left so
you can is so you can keep playing the
game right yeah all right but when he
goes to e8 yeah yep so you're like the
fork and the thing he like we want to
get right in his face and be like
checkmate okay so yeah there's nowhere
to go so so if you look at what black
did in that game you know instead of
trying to get as a dark square Bishop to
move one time you know he made a lot of
knight moves for no reason you know like
that night yeah you just want to get get
your Bishop out get castled and and then
and then try an attack here but but
wasted way too much time all right so
now here's the final game
Matthew manly against Aaron Lynn and
Matthew who saw that his competitor
Kirby checkmated with a bishop and he
did not want to be outshined okay so
let's check out this funny checkmate
here okay so Matthew has the white
pieces against Aaron and Aaron usually
plays much better than this even though
he's still a youngster and getting
better every day but this this wasn't
his best performance
yes Queen's Gambit which it kind of lets
his uh all of Aaron's pieces get very
activated now so not not the best
opening for white when there's so many
other good ones
yeah so Zoe broke the pin with the
bishop so so now Aaron makes a mistake a
lot of amateurs do and and tries to
chase out the bishop by doing this when
you get castle later on you're gonna
have a lot a lot of weak squares you
know so you good there's no reason to
really really do that all right so he
thinks like wow I'm gonna get your night
for the bishop there's nowhere your
bishop can go where it cannot get
captured yeah
but the Queen can just take it not very
good nice I hope I hope Ben Simon can
can put in the caption on that one
because that was it was a great one I
was like all right yep yep there goes
there was a hole of yeah and like in the
previous game you know we're White has
you know the knight black to save it
nope so Queen takes so he takes check
you might as well take his other pawn
just take all his stuff you know you're
up you might as well just just trade it
all night takes check King up a knight
retreats no nothing to pin here
all right Knight retreats King up rook
so now notice he put his knight in a pin
but I don't think it's really gonna hurt
him so now he's threatening he's got
another pin go in there and he's got
that going well when he plays check he's
in no risk of getting Brooke takes Chuck
because black is in check so King out a
check so rook takes rook takes
threatening looked to see one check
winning the
wait rook so what should white play here
yeah you could play King to d1 candy to
Castle you could play Knight to c3
but castling just the easiest so Bishop
attacks the knight knight retreats King
moves plays h3 doesn't that want to get
back rope checkmated notice black has a
light squared bishop so doesn't have to
worry about that that's why h3 was much
better than g3 because then there's no
risk of a backrub checkmate all right
well I mean he's died a lot of pieces
but you know he's never gonna quit
fighting so you got it you gotta like
that above them so big check here why
can't black take the knight this block
has isolated because he's in an absolute
pin right so he moves some Knight moves
look over g4 exploiting the pin because
a pawn takes on the computer computers
not even letting them do it cuz it still
had a pinned right depth on isn't a lot
of pins alright so sorry matters what
just take the pawn and at least
distracted uh Matthew from what he was
doing he was trying to you know
checkmate the King but I think now he's
gonna well I'll play check first and now
yeah just yeah yeah don't even bother
all right
yeah he's going he's going for he's
going for it but not really that way
that was not the best move on the board
for black not that he's been making
great moves all in all in a row that d7
but where could he go AB 7 with the
check via d7 okay fork fork it's a
double it's a double attack as a fork so
he's attacking both the king and the
rook simultaneously and life is good
but remember he wants to get a funny
checkmate here okay so so let's try to
get a funny checkmate going alright he's
got a big Queen now why it's lost I know
I do not like your evaluation all right
what do you think about the bishop right
now he wants to get the king okay
and he wants to do as fast as humanly
possible okay so we got a lot of great
checks here I gotta say white anybody
have a guess how it Queen down okay down
where there there there f5
alright have I'm that looks pretty good
alright but he plays rook to f4 check
King up so and so now it's easy we just
get the King to the edge of the board
and we checkmate them right
okay so play queen Chuck now do we have
a funny checkmate here good what's the
funny checkmate no that's not funny
Bishop e2 and you can laugh at your
opponent and just gotcha okay so those
were some funny checkmates from just 16
thank you very much